these days emotions run high during
meetings of the women's committee in
Bhutan doe Township fear in the
community is palpable Bhutan doe is
located in Zambia's copper mining belt
the slag heaps from the mines begin
right on the edge of town dust and
poisonous fumes are making people sick
[Music]
we mainly fear chest problems we also
have people bleeding from their noses
especially children many have irritated
eyes and some have a rash Peter think
amber is an environmental activist from
Zambia a few years ago he founded the
aid organization citizens for a better
environment
he and his organization support the
women of Bhutan Dome people have
undergone a lot of suffering because of
environmental injustice the mining
operations here which have affected them
through the emissions especially the
acid mist emissions from the tailings
leach plant which the mining operation
here has to make sure the people are
being heard Petersen cambers
organization fights in court against the
mining companies the mining industry is
the backbone of the Zambian economy
mining companies are very powerful and
environmental concerns are extremely
difficult to address this copper ore
heap in Bhutan dough is sprayed every
night with sulfuric acid the wind
carries the acid mist throughout the
entire village initially the mining
company put up some mitigation measures
but they have not worked out the people
is supposed to be not located and it is
very clear that government is not keen
to get them out so we our next step is
to go to court
the residents say acid rain is eating
holes into the roofs of their houses and
nothing grows in the family gardens
anymore
children suffer the most from this
severe environmental pollution
Elizabeth nika's ways grandson is at the
doctor's office all the time the boy
couldn't breathe and had pain in his
chest and he started bleeding from his
nose and developed a rash we went to the
hospital and he got an asthma inhaler
his father has the same problem it
started three years ago access to the
industrial park is barred for camera
teams while driving by we see tanker
trucks on the roadside they are loaded
with sulfuric acid the copper ore heaps
like almost everything around Bhutan
dough belonged to the Swiss mining
company multi Glencore this is the
smelter which is responsible for the
emissions affecting the people in terms
of their chest problems eye problems and
so on and so forth in 2013 he founded
the Green Party of Zambia by going into
politics he now plans to fight the
consequences of Zambia's environmental
destruction at the national level